merci madame la parole est à monsieur
jérôme chartier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez dit au sujet de la grèce de
faire preuve de responsabilité mais
faire preuve de responsabilité ne pas
dire s'inquiéter légitimement et en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui les français
s'inquiètent ils s'inquiètent de savoir
si la situation que vivent les grecs
aujourd'hui ne serait pas une situation
que pourrait vivre les français demain
et je vous poser trois questions très
précises
la première question c'est le déficit du
premier trimestre 2015 plus de 52
milliards d'euros c'est le plus gros
déficit constaté depuis plus de 30 ans
en un seul trimestre la cour des comptes
aujourd'hui s'inquiètent sur cette
augmentation extrêmement importante du
déficit budgétaire français monsieur le
premier ministre
est-ce que vous avez pris conscience de
cette augmentation vertigineuse du
déficit
deuxième question c'est l'information
que nous avons ce matin en commission
des finances en l'occurrence entre les
recettes prévues et les recettes
réalisées l'an dernier en 2014 il y a
dix milliards d'écart 10 milliards
d'écart
alors monsieur le premier ministre est
ce que ces 10 milliards vous allez les
compenser par du déficit en plus ou es
ce que vous avez décidé de faire des
économies supplémentaires et la
troisième question c'est à propos de la
situation en grèce justement hier la
grèce a fait défaut elle est en défaut
de paiement
ça veut dire que les marchés financiers
s'affolent et que bien sûr il vit risque
d'y avoir des répercussions sur les taux
d'intérêt de la dette française on
risque d'emprunter plus cher alors
monsieur le premier ministre tout
simplement
avez vous prévu aujourd'hui dans le
budget français une hausse possible des
taux d'intérêt des bons du trésors
nationaux
monsieur le premier ministre il ya
quelques années un premier ministre en
exercice a eu le courage de dire que la
france était dans une situation de
faillite
alors je vous pose cette question
directe est ce qu'aujourd'hui la france
est en situation de faillite
merci la parole est à monsieur christian
eckert secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget et animale merci monsieur le
maire mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député jérôme chartier tout
d'abord je voudrais vous reprendre
vous évoquez un déficit au premier
trimestre de 57 noms s'agit pas du
déficit les chiffres de l'insee concerne
la dette la dette souscrite durant le
premier trimestre par la france ce n'est
pas la même chose et ce montant
supérieur en tout cas en terme de taux
par rapport au pib est tout à fait
habituelle à cette période de l'année
tous les ans tous les ans mais là
messieurs les députés
en début d'année les émissions de
d'obligations sont plus importants
pourquoi parce que vous le savez les
recettes sont beaucoup plus nombreuses
en fin d'année seuls de l'impôt sur le
revenu taxe d'habitation taxes foncières
et je vous confirme monsieur le député
que cette année la prévision du taux
d'endettement de notre pays reste fixé à
96,3 % c'est le chiffre sur lequel nous
nous sommes engagés et qui sera respecté
deuxièmement vous faites allusion aux
taux d'intérêt et à la nécessaire
prudence par rapport aux taux d'intérêts
aujourd'hui à l'instant il était sur les
eaux a été de 10 ans de 1,19 pour cent
alors que alors que les marchés sont
plutôt secoué vous vous en doutez nous
avons prévu en 2015 un taux de 1,20
c'est à dire même si nous sommes dans un
pic aujourd'hui des taux d'intérêt nous
sommes encore inférieur à nos prévisions
en 2016 vous êtes assis 2,1 en 2010 7 3%
c'est à dire que nous avons pris une
certaine marche de sécurité par rapport
à ce qui peut toujours arriver alors
c'est toujours un peu facile de faire la
course à l'échalote pour être le plus
grands lanceurs d'alert possible le
mouvement le gouvernement reste attentif
vigilant mais cette dette est
parfaitement contrôlée merci